I got a voicemail about that.
If you want to leave me a voicemail, you can
do so at two one nine two.
David P. Here is a voicemail about the pardons.
David, although highly unlikely.
Do you believe that Trump could pardon the
criminals of the recent.
Siege on the capital, because, you know, they're
patriots, right, and he's a law and order
president, so certainly Trump could do it,
but he would need to know who they are.
And it's going to be a long process.
I'm expecting it to take beyond Donald Trump's
last day in office, January 20th to figure
out who all the folks are.
And even if they figure out who most of the
folks are, figuring out what charges are going
to be filed.
So I think in practical terms, Donald Trump's
not going to be able to do it.
I did hear from a lot of people who said they
should actually slow play the investigation
specifically to prevent Trump from being able
to pardon them so Trump could do it.
I think logistically there will be challenges
because we're not going to know all of the
charges for a period of time.
But bigger picture than that, Trump is worried
about himself.
You have to remember, Trump doesn't care about
these people.
The people that support Trump mostly are people
Trump has spent his life of privilege trying
to get away from.
You know, Trump talks about the boaters in
the intercoastal in Florida.
He talks about the coal workers in West Virginia
or whatever.
Trump has spent a life having people keep
him away from what he considers to be that
kind of riff raff.
And so Trump doesn't care about these people.
And in fact, there are reports which are sort
of sad and also funny just because of it exposes
the things Trump thinks about.
Trump was reportedly displeased that the rioters
last week looked low.
Class, if you can, about Trump wanted the
he would have preferred the people rioting,
I guess, to to all have flown in on private
jets and only a couple of them actually did.
So Trump doesn't care about these people at
all.
If he thought it was politically advantageous,
he might try to to pardon them.
But he's leaving office.
It's over.
And so Trump's concerns are, am I going to
pardon myself and would it hold up legally?
And he's been advised by some folks around
him not to pardon himself.
And is he going to pardon his children and
his son in law and Rudy Giuliani and whoever
else?
That's what Trump is concerned with.
And I am expecting we will see some really
wacky pardons in the last seven days.
But I have no expectation that Donald Trump
is actually going to try to pardon those people
because he doesn't care about the rioters.
And in fact, he didn't like their appearance.
He thought that they seem to lowbrow.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Another member of Congress is now positive
after sheltering in place at the Capitol during
the riotous insurrection.
Many Republicans refused to wear masks during
that period of time.
We will also talk about the future of coronavirus
coronavirus not expected to go away even after
everybody is vaccinated, but its impact is
going to be lessened dramatically.
And we will talk about why.
And more riot firings continue.
More companies deciding, whoa, you were involved
with the violence in DC on January 6th.
This is not the right place for you to work.
You're gone.
So we will talk about that on the bonus show
as well.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman Dotcom.
I'll s